veamos si podemos aplicar lo que hemos
aprendido en los vídeos pasados para
resolver este complicado problema déjeme
ver cómo lo puedo construir digamos que
aquí va a haber una resistencia
de 4 oms
que va a estar en paralelo con otra
resistencia
8 11
que además va a estar en paralelo con
otra resistencia
de 1611 y para que nuestros números
salgan bonitos vamos a poner otra cuarta
resistencia en paralelo
que también va a valer 1611
a su vez va a estar
junto a una resistencia quien que va a
valer un homme
y todo esto va a tener una resistencia
en paralelo
de 3 oms
además vamos a tener por acá otra
resistencia de un ojo para mantener los
números sencillos
y finalmente
aquí vamos a tener nuestra batería
terminal positiva terminal negativa y va
a tener un voltaje de 20 volts
quiero que hagamos es calcular cuál es
la corriente la corriente qué pasa
en este punto del circuito nuestra
corriente total cual es si bueno la
forma más sencilla de hacer esto es
calcular la resistencia equivalente de
las que tengo en paralelo acá y una vez
que conozco esta resistencia equivalente
pues resolvemos este el mazo de
resistencias
ahora así podremos usar la ley de ohm
para encontrar la corriente
vamos a comenzar por esta sección más
interna
esta sección de aquí
encontramos que la resistencia
equivalente de estas cuatro resistencias
en paralelo va a ser 1 entre 4 + 1 entre
8 + 1 entre 16 más de nuevo 1 entre 16
son los valores de cada una de estas
resistencias en paralelo hacemos la suma
de fracciones
nos va a quedar tenemos un común
denominador de 16
1 / 4 su equivalente en dieciseisavos es
4 más un octavo lo multiplicamos todo
por 22 dieciseisavos más un dieciseisavo
más otro dieciseisavos hacemos la suma
cuatro más dos son 6 más 17 + 18
dieciseisavos que es lo mismo a un medio
por lo que mi resistencia equivalente en
esta sección es igual a 211
encontramos que estas cuatro
resistencias combinadas son equivalentes
a dos somos y ahora permítanme borrar
esto
de acá
y reescribir nuestro circuito vamos a
hacer esto más grande que no nos tome
tanto tiempo borramos estoy acá para
dibujar
nuestro circuito o nuestra resistencia
equivalente que acabamos de encontrar
y nuestra resistencia equivalente
en esta sección encontramos
es de dos hombres
ahora vamos a analizar esta sección de
acá donde tenemos estas dos resistencias
en
serie como vimos cuando las resistencias
están en serie vamos a sumar las
así que tenemos que esta resistencia
equivalente va a ser igual a la suma de
esta resistencia de 211
más esta resistencia de un hombre y nos
queda que esto es igual a 3 oms y así de
sencillo estoy
y así de sencillo estoy simplificando
todo esto
problema inicial que se había bastante
denso por algo mucho más sencillo nos
queda entonces que éste
que en esta sección nuestra resistencia
combinada aquí
es de 3 11
y ahora sí que nos está quedando algo
muy sencillo a que son equivalentes
estos dos registros en paralelo
no vamos a hacerlo en otro color estos
dos registros que están acá
van a ser igual
como están en paralelo es uno entre la
resistencia equivalente va a ser igual a
1 entre 3 oms
1 / 3 oms
los sumamos dos tercios
y nos queda que la resistencia es igual
a tres medios de homs
o lo que es lo mismo es igual a 1.5 o 2
y ahora podemos proceder a borrar toda
esta sección y simplificar la pero antes
de hacerlo esta bifurcación es un muy
buen ejemplo para explicar qué es lo que
sucede aquí porque aunque tenemos aquí
resistencia es de 3 oms
tenemos dos de ellas y podemos ver como
que incrementamos la tubería por la que
circulan los electrones por un factor de
2 por lo que estamos de crem en tanto la
resistencia es decir le estamos dando
más opciones o más rutas a los
electrones para pasar y es por eso que
la resistencia combinada de estas dos es
la mitad que cualquiera de ellas les
dijo esto para que reflexionen al
respecto aunque voy a hacer un vídeo
sobre resistencias exclusivamente ahora
sí vamos a eliminar esta sección
dándonos la resistencia equivalente aquí
1.5 11
ahora nos quedan estas dos resistencias
que están en serie
la resistencia total equivalente va a
ser 1.5 + 1
211 ahora vamos a dibujar para no tener
que borrar de nuevo repetir todo
el circuito final con una resistencia
acá
batería acá la batería es de 20 volts
por terminar positiva terminal negativa
esta resistencia equivalente es la suma
de estas dos 2.5 oms
ahora si podemos aplicar la ley de hoy
quedamos que la ley de ohm es voltaje
igual a resistencia por corriente
sustituimos voltajes de 20 la
resistencia es de 2.5 aquí tenemos la
corriente
podemos decir también que esto podemos
decir que este 2.5 es igual las 5 medios
aquí es más fácil trabajar con con
fracciones
por la corriente despejamos la corriente
es igual a dos quintos de 20
que nos da un total de 8am pers esto no
estuvo tan mal aunque cuando vimos la
configuración inicial sería
tremendamente complicada bueno sí
comprendieron esto ya resolvieron un
problema bastante complicado de
circuitos y nos veremos en el siguiente
vídeo